- Oh, Lord, look at that!
- In Louisiana, we have
a population explosion
in alligators.
And what we seen
on the ground with our eyes
I think is a fraction
of what’s out there.
But from in the air,
I think we’re gonna be
a lot more accurate,
especially
with the nest population.
For every nest
you see out there,
that’s a mature female.
And that mature female
can have between 30 and 50 eggs.
So if you got 10 nests
in an area,
all of a sudden
you’re gonna have 300 to 500
new little alligators.
The last few years,
because of the price of gators,
a lot of hunters
aren’t hunting no more.
And it’s hard to believe
how much the population
has gotten out of control.
And I’m scared, I’m very scared,
it’s only gonna get worse.
I mean, what’s gonna stop it?
What’s gonna slow it down?
- It’s not just near the water.
These gators are coming into
the communities
where there’s no water at all,
and everybody
in the community’s on edge.
The women are scared to death
for their kids and their pets.
Right now, I feel it’s like
the revenge of the alligators.
It’s like
they coming for us now.